It's now my privilege to sign the
Homeland Security Act.
The Department of Homeland Security
will have nearly 170,000
employees.
The threat of mass murder on our own
soil will be
met with a unified, effective
response.
So the Department of Homeland
Security, DHS, is celebrating
its 20th birthday, which is a
perfect opportunity to rethink
the whole concept of homeland
security and how to best
provide it.
DHS has grown into a monster
child that is massively expensive,
incredibly ineffective and
reliably destructive of basic
civil liberties.
It's time to abolish it and
replace it with fewer, smaller and
more accountable agencies.
In the wake of the 9/11 attacks,
President George W.
Bush called for the creation of a
new Cabinet-level department,
whose primary mission is to protect
the American homeland.
By pulling border security,
emergency services and immigration
into a single, streamlined
bureaucracy, Bush promised
that the new department would
improve efficiency without
growing government.
Instead, we got politically
manipulated, color-coded terror
alerts that only made it easier
for late night comedians.
The threat level is now
magenta.
The DHS budget now stands at
$82 billion, or
almost double its original cost in
inflation-adjusted dollars.
Are there really twice as many
threats to the homeland as there
were when the embers at Ground
Zero were still smoldering
and the global war on terror was
just ramping up.
In the early days of the war on
terror, Washington was obsessed
with the idea that the 9/11 attacks
happened because different agencies,
notably the CIA, FBI
and NSA, didn't communicate
with each other.
Hence the idea of a unified homeland
security structure.
But critics of DHS noted from
the start that it didn't actually
reduce bureaucracy or streamline
much of anything.
It just added a new layer of red
tape on top of existing
agencies while creating new ones
such as the Customs and Border
Patrol and Immigration and Customs
Enforcement, both of which have
become legendary for callousness
and root-level failures.
Similarly, the Federal Emergency
Management Agency, FEMA,
has gone from catastrophic failure
in New Orleans all the way to
catastrophic failure in Puerto Rico,
updating its long standing, stumble
bum reputation for the 21st
century.
In a new report, FEMA admits
failures occurred in its disaster
response to Hurricane Maria.
A 2019 inspector general
report called out DHS
for failing to rein in bad behavior,
ranging from padding expense
accounts to drinking on the job
to illegal reprisals against
sexual harassment whistleblowers.
The report concluded no one was
really in charge of organizing and
inspecting reports of employee
misbehavior.
President Biden has boasted that DHS
has almost 260,000
employees, yet its H.R.
department told the inspector
general it had limited staffing
to perform these functions, and
staff do not believe they are
responsible for managing the
allegation process.
Perhaps worst of all, DHS
is a determined foe of civil
liberties.
As the ACLU documents in a
new study of the department, DHS
routinely undermines our ability
to speak and move freely about the
very country it's supposed
to be protecting.
For instance, since immigration
enforcement became part of a
national security agenda,
ICE agents encourage local police
to stop, arrest and bring low-level
charges against people who look like
immigrants, with the actual aim
of helping ICE deport them.
Looking like an immigrant isn't
against the law, and it shouldn't be
a pretext for a police stop.
And when we talk about DHS, of
course we have to talk about the
Transportation Security
Administration, TSA.
Oh, curse the brilliant
TSA!
Which you might refer to as
"Thousands Standing Around," the
"Testicle Squeezing Agency"
or any number of different
euphemisms.
Despite very occasional positive
headlines, the TSA rightly
looms large in the public
imagination as a make-work
program gone horribly wrong.
Famous for forcing mothers to drink
their own breast milk, scaring
children and panting the elderly,
the TSA reportedly spends as
much as $667 billion
per life saved.
On its 10th anniversary, two
conservative Republican members of
Congress even denounced the TSA,
saying the degraded security
theater it imposed on travelers
did not improve on the safety
protocols that were in place before
9/11.
DHS's mission is simply
too vast to accomplish.
Having been tasked to do so many
different things, from processing
immigration checks, to responding to
natural disasters, to checking
passengers on every flight in
America, to stopping terrorism,
it ends up doing all of them
poorly.
It would be better to break those
functions up into smaller agencies
that are directly accountable to
departments that existed prior to
9/11.
As Richard A.
Clarke, a 30 year veteran of
security positions in the Defense
Department, State Department and
White House, has suggested
it makes sense to create a smaller
group, tightly focused on
terroristic threats that would
work directly with the FBI and the
Office of National Intelligence.
"Preserving the status quo," he
writes, "will only perpetuate
the mistakes made in the panic
trauma that followed 911
and doom these important missions
to continued mishandling and
lack of success." As it celebrates
its 20th birthday, its
time to blow out the candles on DHS.